foreign
[Music]
moving
uh the royal family
um what else I want to read some
comments today go through some comments
I don't usually do that let's do that on
the episode today and a little q a in
the chat
[Music]
check out
damn a voice is messed up because
I just have some sushi with uh Rachel
Rachel brought Rachel just brought some
sushi first of all I'm not wet take home
sushi
but she went down to this uh place
um right just down the street and it I
love this place you know so she got a
suit you can't let Sushi sit you got to
eat sushi right away but anyways we'll
talk about that ladies and gentlemen
welcome to another episode of riffing
with Griffin
your favorite stream of conscious
Consciousness uh podcast with Eric
Griffin if you're here for your first
time welcome maybe you're looking for a
comedy podcast sometimes it is sometimes
it isn't this is for the new people the
new people you know I I have comedy on
other podcasts you could check out the
golden hour you could check out
um Jen to Jen with Matthew Espinosa but
on this one it's just stuff that's in my
head and it comes out sometimes it's
funny sometimes it's thoughtful
sometimes it's deep sometimes it's silly
but this is what it is this is me uh for
the people that have been here all the
time you already know this thanks for
being here so you don't have to you know
say whatever you're gonna say it is what
it is all right that should be the name
of the podcast is what it is but welcome
to Griffin with Griffin
Please Subscribe share uh hit the likes
um all that because it helps grow to
podcast uh as you know I'm on Twitter
I'll be on Twitter right after this on
Eric Griffin gaming it's also a way to
support the show you can be a Twitter
sub help support me which is great other
ways are you could be a patreon member
which this week I am going to do a
patreon episode so you got this you
could be a patreon member or you could
be a YouTube member all those people get
the whatever extra content and messages
and stuff it goes there so I appreciate
that and
also I'm coming your way in
2023 already got a few dates and more
dates are coming if you want to come
check me out live please do come check
me out live I still got my terrible
podcast but it is what it is uh uh where
is my screen that capture things boom
there it is right there so I'm coming to
The Comedy Zone in Greensboro North
Carolina January 13th through the 15th
the Newberry in Great Falls Montana
Newberry coming your way February 25th
and then there's other dates coming up
later but those are the two ones that
are coming up soon but especially the
comedy zone in Greensboro January 13th
through 15th so come check me out there
make sure you come see that all right
okay now
um
now a word from our sponsor
this show riff River Griffin is
sponsored by better Help Therapy online
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists available 100 online
learn more and save 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com Griffin
okay uh what's up y'all so anyway as I
was saying uh Rachel is out here oh and
thank you Janine for the Super Chat
that's another way you can support the
show hit me with a super chat or super
whatever the YouTube always has some new
stuff there so I I do uh appreciate that
uh if you want to send me a beat also
for the rap recap uh for the end of the
show as I do my old man rap style you
can send me if you're a producer out
there and you're like I want my beat
featured on riffen with Griffin send
that you know I got I have like a number
of really great young producers or old I
don't know they seem young but they
could be old too whatever but they send
me stuff and I put it out there so I
appreciate that so anyway you support
the show I appreciate you so um anyways
anyways we got
um
yeah Rachel she just brought some sushi
home you know and I don't know how y'all
feel about sushi you know take home
Sushi I don't know about take-home Sushi
I think you're supposed to
um
you know
I think you're supposed to like I think
there was like I saw a whole thing about
like you have to eat sushi right away it
has to be at a certain temperature so
like the place is right down the street
so I know she brought it right home and
it was very fresh tasting so I actually
sat down there a little bit and like I
gobbled some down because if you let it
sit you don't want to you don't want to
have sit let it sit Sushi you know what
I mean
I'm gonna put up a little q a for the
the chat
um
uh b-roll device from I haven't done
this in a while grown ass man I'll just
do this one live if anybody has any
things right there so I'll put that in
uh for the chat right there no poll
right now oh you know it's something I
didn't put in the um something I didn't
put in the what do you call it uh
the the description I thought I might
want to get into but I don't know
because you know there's this big talk
of this uh uh Brittany Greiner trade for
the you know the things so many people
talking about that right so it's just
like I guess I'll get my thoughts on
that too
um and then I want to get and then today
I'm also like I said I'm going to read
some comments from people I you know I
get a lot of comments and you know some
good some bad you know some are
thoughtful and I just thought you know
what let me give some people some shout
out who've given me
asked about things on the show
you know previously previous episodes
and stuff like that so
we'll go into that stuff too so I was in
uh Austin this past weekend past week I
was in Austin I did I did a Erica
friends at Creek in the cave and shout
out to all the comics that were out
already out there like David Lucas uh he
moved to to Austin he's out there Brian
Simpson both of these dudes super funny
and so different you know this but
they're both so different but super
funny and they're hanging out a lot with
Rogan like Rogan is always giving them
love so they out there with him
sometimes they go on the road with him
and go to theaters and stuff so they're
doing great Ryan Simpson is just a
really funny dude man you gotta check
him out
um and yeah so I did a show the creek in
the cave and then guess who was in town
Bobby Lee was in town so Bobby came by
and did a set at the show too which was
uh which was great he was in town doing
something with Tom Segura the your mom's
house people so and so he like hit me up
and then we were gonna go to like lunch
or dinner but I was out in Austin doing
something specific which was I was
directing my boy Matt rife's special
I don't know if you guys have seen Matt
Rife or you know who he is I've had him
on the podcast before handsome young
dude uh you know now he's just a a young
man now it's freaking
you know what I mean it's actually it's
actually freaking crazy his Instagram
keeps getting shut down which doesn't
make any sense you know but I think it's
just haters
you know but he uh he's been doing I've
known him since he was like uh
15 years old 14 years old you know he
came to um
he came to my show in Pittsburgh so he
was like he was really Adam me like he
would hit you up on Twitter and be like
hey I'm trying to be a comic I'm a fan
of yours comic comic comedy he just
would we're Relentless you know so you
just like see him a good looking kid
you're like all right let me see what's
up with this kid so we started talking
we built up a friendship and I was like
listen I'm coming to Pittsburgh and he
was like I'll take a bus if you give me
a guest set he took a bus at like 15 16
years old took a bus to Pittsburgh and I
put him on stage and he bombed horribly
I wish I had to tape so funny how much
he bombed
um and then you know he just kept doing
it kept doing it and he came to LA and
when he was gonna move to LA he just was
gonna turned 18 was like I'm moving to
LA and so he no he wasn't even 18 yet
actually and I let him stay with me for
a couple weeks and then I took him
around to the comedy club and I was like
yo this kid he really wants to do it and
you know and cut two now he's literally
one of the biggest comics on
uh Tick Tock you know his first special
is already out there so I do recommend
you and I and I Loosely directed that
one but I just it was a whole thing
um so but and that one is on yeah it's
called only fans that's it that's the
name of his special it the name of his
special is called only fans and you
could see it on
YouTube right now you know you can see
it on YouTube and so it's it's on
YouTube for free uh uh he's got like I
don't know how many he's yeah he's got
1.4 million views on the special that
was 11 months ago and this is how he's
doing it he's you know he's doing it his
own way and I I so admire that you know
he very much is like this new generation
of comics that has taken advantage of
um he's taken advantage of what's going
on out here and the funny thing about
him that I admire the most is like I
used to tell him all the time dude you
got to get on social media you gotta and
he he was adamant that he didn't want to
do it that way he was like oh man I
don't want to do that I don't have the
he didn't have the energy for it he
didn't want to be somebody that has to
make funny clips and all this kind of
stuff he would he really wanted to be a
stand-up so cut to a few months back
maybe a little longer than that he like
started putting up his stand-up Clips
you know and he was like doing some
crowd work and he did this one that
really resonated with people and it blew
up 800 000 followers on Tick Tock like
this and now he has videos on Tick Tock
that have
40 million views he's got a number of
tick tock videos that are 40 million
views and then that led to people coming
to see him live he's selling out
theaters like the Wilbur I mean the
Wilbur is like a place that like you
know
every comic wants to do I've never even
done it you know what I mean and he sold
out three shows at the Wilbur so it is
just like a new generation of comic and
I I I'm super proud of him like you know
there's no jealousy or anything like
that in my heart you know you have but
you know you you could be jealous
because I'm like damn I wish I was able
to do that and in the same breath I'm
like I'm so proud of this dude because
he's like a little brother to me you
know what I mean I showed him how to
shave that's the kind of relationship we
have you know
um so so cut to it was time now for this
one this new one he's doing and I was
like I'm directing this one for sure and
so I went out and you know we had a
bunch of meetings and then you were
talking to the crew and the shout out to
the crew man they were great Evan and
everybody the sound guy I mean everybody
was so good on this on the crew and we
got some really beautiful shots we shot
it at the Vulcan and the vulcan's this
weird two-story like rock club venue
type thing and but there were people on
the balcony and it was just we got these
amazing shots and it was just something
that's a new thing I want to get into
which is like you know directing so
we'll see how it goes uh but I'm sure
it's gonna come out great and then you
know he's already uh you know putting
out posts to be like hey let's get some
funding for the next one like he's
totally down to just like do it on his
own he don't care about Netflix and all
this kind of stuff if they want to give
him money to do it he's like cool but
it's like I'll do this myself I don't
need anyone and I just like that's just
the way to go we don't need in these
Gatekeepers who think that they
understand comedy and they just only
putting out a certain type of Comedy you
got to be this or that and and hear
these young kids are coming up and
they're like yo we're going to do it our
way and you know what I really um
I don't know I I I just admire that so
shout out to him and so what check out
my directorial debut sometime in a few
months the new special is gonna his
special be out and it'll say produced
and directed by Eric Griffin so I can't
wait for that
um all right well yeah so there's that
uh
I don't name it now so what else is
going on
um yeah so let's get into I want to get
into a few comments uh you know from
people yeah let me see if there's any
questions in my thing and shout out to
everybody that listens to the podcast
too later I appreciate you on that so
you know what I mean wait how do I I
don't even know how to get to this this
is so weird like how do you get to
I don't know if there's anybody has even
I don't think anybody's even asked a
question on the Q a so because I'm not
even sure how to
get to it like I see it right here oh I
guess there's just no questions anyways
um all right so I want to get to a
comment so last week I was talking about
solar
and and uh you know it's like solar is
weird like it seems that it's a
technology that it's not quite where it
possibly could be or in my my thoughts
so my thoughts were like
it seems like there's a cap on what solo
can do and is it the fact that like
they're not putting enough technology
towards that or is it being suppressed
because the electric people and the gas
people are like yo we don't want you to
get this super free energy
um oh I oh somebody's just asked me
right now you should put up oh actually
I do have a Discord too that's that's so
true I do have a Discord I actually
started I actually start should start
bringing super fans on to the show you
know what I mean but I do have a Discord
if anybody's interested uh you know I
gotta just put that I gotta figure out
what get that link in I forgot how to do
that I'm not gonna do that right now I
don't even know why I even mentioned it
but you know I do have a Discord so next
week
I'll put that into things you guys can
start checking out my Discord
um but anyways I was talking about the
solar and so I got a message from
somebody Tres Novak t-r-e-z that's how
you say his name trezino
I've worked in the solo industry for
multiple years it would be amazing if
there was a solar technology that was
efficient enough to either
simultaneously charge the vehicle while
it was driving and that be effective
enough to drive zero to 80 miles per
hour as far as solar energy replacement
for electricity usage there's
significant amount of grid grid tied
systems off-grid systems where where yes
large battery banks are needed there is
going to come up a pin a point where the
majority Drive electric vehicles and the
massive issue there are people charging
their cars at home and charging stations
we will get our electricity from the
National Grid the natural grid can never
be replaced only worked on with when it
fails power outages blackout Center are
going to become a massive issue that's
what this guy thinks you know he thinks
it's going to be a massive issue so you
know and you know I've heard this a lot
he goes on it's a really long uh comment
so I'm not going to go all into that
but yeah I mean so that's something that
they keep talking about that this is
going to be a massive issue when more
electric cars are on the grid and what
are we going to do and when are they
going to charge them is there going to
be enough power so I mean you would just
think that they hopefully are going to
like work on this are they going to have
like you know uh Big Win Win things in
the middle of the country that's going
to be charging things are we going to
have big more solar panels in the desert
so like what are we going to do to
ensure that we have more technology
available for you know for solar I don't
know we'll have to see right hopefully
it's something that
um you know will
so hopefully there's something that's
going to get worked on all right all
right let me go to
um one of my comments on Instagram sorry
sorry on Instagram I don't I had to turn
the volume down on that so I I did get I
did get a lot of Instagram comments from
last week when
from last week's episode when I put up
this thing about Kanye West so
lots and lots of uh
comments about this man
um
but you know I guess I don't even know
if I want to read any of these because
some of these are just kind of like I
think sometimes people are missing the
point I just want to say something about
this point about last week about Kanye
for instance because I just saw a thing
now where Kanye was saying hey I did all
this because I wanted to get out of my
contract you know as if that's some sort
of like justifies things I mean it
really to me it's it's still dangerous
to think that
there are people out there who are
listening to the things he says for
instance about Jewish people about oh
they should be working for Christians
and all the all the sort of things he
was saying that inspired people who are
out there with this nonsense of like we
know he had a point about some of the
things he was saying just because you
have a point about something it doesn't
mean how you made your point is okay or
that there was no one affected about you
making some great point you know make it
a great Point like being honest or what
that doesn't excuse you from being an
[__]
it doesn't excuse you from hurting
people's feelings and I can speak to
this as a comedian because our intention
is to make people laugh and there are
people that we talk about within the
jokes who may look at that and be like
hey why are you using us as the butt of
the joke but overall the intention is
for laughter for me at least you know so
this is It's a fine line but when you
have someone you're saying that his
intention was I got into a deal that I
no longer want to be in and how I'm
going to get out of this deal is I'm
going to put a lot of negativity and
bring up a lot of polarizing things
about Jewish people so then I'll get a
bunch of hate and then Adidas will get
me out of my contract oh great but you
know what there are people out there who
were like he's right and then now
they're on the freeway with signs and
they're in people's comments you know
with all their hate and Kanye's just
using you he's using you too you know
you're sitting out here thinking that oh
this is my prophet and he's saying stuff
that's gonna yeah man you're right and
he's just out here like nah man I'm just
trying to make money and get out of this
dumb deal so I can get into a better
deal and make all the money myself he
don't care about you so you out here you
out here like yeah Kanye's right and
then he's making you look stupid because
he's like I don't really actually care
I'm just trying to make my own money if
that's the case that'll make it right I
don't agree with that either I don't
agree with that process you know because
it was it was I don't know man it just
it left a bad taste in my mouth for that
you know it really did
all right
um what I'll do is let me go back and
look at some other
I had some other comments from some from
some other episodes you know
um
yeah from a v Julian absolutely loved
Wednesday this is from two weeks ago
she's my favorite TV show character of
all time uh they did one
it was amazing I was a bit iffy when the
initially indicated her vision something
she has historically never access
exercised but they sold me yeah and then
somebody you rock Eric thank you I
appreciate that yeah man I really like I
say when I look back on that episode or
the show I actually watched the whole
show again I've actually never done that
on a Netflix show Once I watch it once I
have never gone back and been like hey
let me take a look at that again but I
actually went back I was just because I
was on the road I was on the planes I
had already had it downloaded and I was
like let me start watching this again
and I was like oh yeah it just I I
really loved it so
that was great
and then I had a poll last week and then
um let me see oh no no that's the same
person
oh yeah so here's someone else uh
uh simulation oh sit hot simulator
simulation but spelled really weird I
like that yeah you got me with that one
the question you posed about a boring
night versus best night has a flaw and
that is even if you don't remember the
best night because I'm wasted I can look
through pictures and videos from the
night to assemble some memories so in a
way I will in fact remember the night
uh I don't know about that
I think that there was something about
imagine like
you had the best night of your life you
know
and you like went to to Vegas and Like
You know your dream girl your dream
celebrity girl is there and she sees you
and she's like oh my God I want you take
me now and you're just taking pictures
all night in videos you know you know
maybe it's you and Taylor Swift because
I said Taylor Swift is your jam and you
had a club and Taylor Swift sees you and
she's like oh you are the one and she's
just making out with you and she's
writing a song about you right in front
of you and you're just like oh my God
Taylor's writing a song about me and
she's you know kissing your neck and
then you she takes you into her room and
she just makes passionate love to you
Taylor Swift style whatever that means
probably angry and she's crying don't
hurt me no I'm kidding totally kidding
Taylor Swift don't get mad at me you
know because he's gonna write a great
song about it later
but anyways you know and she's taking
like pictures provocative pictures of
you and her and then but you blacked out
drunk and you don't remember none of it
wouldn't you feel a certain kind of way
when you look on your phone and you see
pictures of you and Taylor Swift and
you're like oh no I what happened she
did what and you have like a a hickey
you know what I mean and you're like I
got a hickey did Taylor Swift give me a
hickey and I don't even remember it
I'm sorry that's not that wouldn't be
enough for me I would be furious at
myself I would just be like oh I had
this night that all I can see is
pictures and I don't even remember what
happened I don't know so I disagree with
you but the question poll was would you
rather have
a a boring night that you remember
everything or or the best night of your
night but you're blacked out drunk and
you don't remember anything the next day
which one would you want so that's what
that poll was about
um
and then somebody get this guy Wayman
put this and I totally agree with this
statement he's put with respect you
can't really ask folks to support you on
patreon but not upload content to
patreon
I totally agree with you that's why
coming shortly
coming shortly is some patreon content
trust me
okay still nobody on the Q a so all
right well I won't worry about that then
you know what I mean I had it there but
it is what it is
one of my I should go to like one of my
one of my most most viewed videos is the
movie review with the Lee Brothers
I wonder if there's any new comments on
here
somebody says Hugo this Trio needs to
happen more often well it is what it is
somebody said the second time I've
watched this how in the hell did Bobby
choose Andrew Santino over this amazing
nerdout geek podcast of film critique
and hilarious stories about Steve and
the gaming and the arguments it's just
the best the funniest hey bad friends is
pretty great too so
shout out to Andrew and Bobby they're
actually going to put on a great show at
The Comedy Store main room so if you're
in the LA area check out the website of
the comic store I'm gonna be on the show
too they're gonna do like bad friends
comedy and then they're going to give
all the proceeds to the door guys for as
a Christmas gift because you know it's a
lot of struggling dudes that work the
door they're like struggling comics and
you know they're going to do that for
them so we'll see
how that goes
um Yeah man so lots of
lots of stuff going on and also like I
said check me out on gender gen podcast
Eric Griffin gaming and the golden hour
make sure you check me out on uh golden
hour
all right let's go into some other stuff
uh I know I haven't really watched it
but this royal family stuff is on Megan
and
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex that's
what their official titles are turns out
his dad I think that Charles is his dad
right yeah I think so is like not taking
their titles away I mean who even cares
like do these titles even mean anything
I guess it means something in England I
think they're I think it's still a big
deal to have this royal family I don't
know but I was looking on there and they
had they actually have a website which I
think is so strange that uh you know
they have this look at this they have
this website that you could go and see
all this stuff about them but it's like
it's not even really I don't think it
doesn't look like they're even keep up
on the website you know it's like uh
it's just like they just have a bunch of
nice picture a couple of nice pictures
and with a little with a little blurb
and then them with people you know what
I mean
it's just I don't know there's the
Desmond Tutu and her with the baby and
it's like they're you know it just looks
like one of those it just looks like one
of those like you know you're they're
trying to like show what good people
they are anytime I see like British
royal people like this and then they're
out at some looks like some African
Countryside and then there's little
there's a little black kid you know
giving him high five I'm just like who's
this for like like what is this you know
so I don't know what's going on with
them I I've seen a bunch of Articles how
people are like sick of them
you know they're like like they're just
done like move on you know if you don't
want to be a part of the royal family
and everything that the royal family
means then just you know go yeah do your
they they have a Netflix special you
know I'm sure they got millions of
dollars to do that and they're just
living in the United States now like hey
we don't want to be a part of all that
Pomp and Circumstance of the royal
family so who knows I mean what an odd
looking couple too you know uh you know
I just
I saw a little bit of the show just to
like like watching them talking about
how they got together and I just thought
to myself are they are they really that
interesting I don't know if they're that
interesting to have a full-on show about
them
has anybody seen them has anybody seen
this show like I don't know if it's even
worth
is it even worth it you know
um I don't know man
I don't I don't know if
like now they're just celebrities
I guess the Obamas did it too I mean I
guess is that the thing that people are
doing now they they're like famous for
whatever they're famous for Infamous for
in some cases and then the Netflix just
goes hey come here because you know what
I noticed is this new trend on Netflix
now it's all these like serial killer
tapes which I didn't even know they were
taping people like that and how did they
even get it like how much money did they
have to pay to get these tapes
but they had the John Wayne Gacy tapes
which I listened to and oh my God
frightening man like that guy was a
scary dude man just the fact you know
you know he was just burying young boys
under his house
27 28 29 and when they finally found him
it's just like God damn and then you're
just listening to him talk about it you
know he's just his General tone so they
made a whole show out of it so I believe
they I believe they got the ten Ted
Bundy also
I think they got yeah do they got the 10
I think they got to let me look it up
Ted Bundy tapes I think
yeah yeah conversations with a killer
the Ted Bundy tapes
oh I think that one already came out
yeah that one already came out okay that
one's an oh well I think that I think
that was the first one they did yeah
that came out in 2019. so I guess
there's like a a Resurgence of it uh
people it's more because of the this
whole Dahmer Fascination that came out
so but yeah man this this sucker is
this sucker is crazy yeah so
conversations with it that's what it's
called conversations with a killer so
they had the the John Wayne Gacy ones
um and then in 2020 20 they had the Ted
Bundy uh falling for a killer well that
was an Amazon series oh okay and then
the Confessions of a killer 2019 these
are all series
yeah yeah wow Jesus
yeah so I I don't know what this big
fascination with that is and sometimes
you just go hey maybe this shouldn't be
made you know what I mean maybe it's
like we just move on from this
all right so one of the uh big things
that's happening right now is like
people are all up in arms about
the Brittany grinder
trade
you know I don't know how I feel about
it I actually can see this is one of
those ones where I see both sides and I
also often have to tell myself let me
remember
let me let me remember that
if that were my family I would want
people to do whatever they can I mean
that's why it's very nuanced you know so
like if just think of it this way if it
was your wife your brother your father
your mother your sister your whoever
that was super close to you is being
detained uh and gonna be detained in
some Russian prison for nine years
and then you would want the government
to do everything they can it's not your
concern to worry about as a family
member and loved one to be like well who
are you getting and then under and then
try to figure out the merits of that so
I understand on this side and then on
the other side you go all right well we
had this guy this butcher uh whatever
this Russian you know arms dealer we've
had him for what 14 years or something
like that
and then they traded they tried to get
other people out but they wouldn't do it
apparently I don't know all the details
we'll never know all the real details
but people are using this
you know as a as as like you know
a thing where it's like well should we
have traded do we get equal value and
and it's like who who are we to decide
that but if you were in the state
department if you are someone who is you
know
a military person or you're a strategist
and you have to think about the greater
good of everyone I can understand
somebody being like well why did we
trade this guy who was responsible for
so Much Death and Destruction for uh you
know a a pseudo celebrity basketball
player
you know who wasn't even who who doesn't
even
come here you know play here that that
often and because there's more money
female basketball it seems to be more
valued in other places than it is here
in the United States
so that's the reason why she did that
but you know and then there's all these
things about her now they're like oh she
was beating her wife and should that you
know should we have traded someone like
this for you know I don't know I don't
know like it's like you have to ask
yourself how you feel about it you know
but I just want you to try to frame it
in a way of thinking about if it was if
it was someone in your family I mean we
all got a family member who's like not
the best person in the whole wide world
but that's your family member you know
what I mean
and you would be like well I want them
to do everything they can to get my
person back and somebody comes to you
and says well your your dad is kind of a
deadbeat you know or your brother didn't
your brother get arrested for
shoplifting or whatever it is like that
and you're going yeah I know but that's
my brother and I want my brother back
you know what I'm saying like I don't
know who are we to decide what it is you
know and I know they're talking about
Paul Whelan that's the guy I you know
they're claiming that they tried to get
Paul wheeling in the deal and Russia was
like no it's either this or nothing
and so who are we to be like nothing
because who do we like who do they care
they just put her in a prison and be
like okay you don't want her well no no
problem and then it just depends on like
how much the public cares here
you know like if the public is calling
for
hey what's going on why why aren't we
getting Brittany Greiner out I mean if
that's the big swell of like things so
then they're like look we got to get her
out because it was so it was so public
it was so
you know what I mean like it was just
the the at the Forefront of the news all
the time especially sports news with
sports are big in our country so it was
just kind of like yo what are we gonna
do
[Music]
um
so I don't know
so then like I think that Paul Whelan's
family they there there was another
trade another prisoner swap before and
they were trying and they were trying to
get him out then and then it didn't
happen and they didn't tell Paul
Whelan's family like yo we're doing this
prisoner swap and but it's not for him
so look out for that in the news and
then they were really upset about that
they were like yo what you know
don't don't fact check me because this
is just like secondhand I remember
hearing about this
so I think that this time they really
made sure to call Paul Wheeler's family
and be like hey
we tried to get him out
they didn't want to give them up so this
is what we're doing so I don't know
and who knows what they asked for
maybe Russia was like all right we'll
give you Paul wheelan and Brittany
Greiner if you do this this and this you
know what I'm saying maybe Russia was
like yo stop giving you know money and
arms to Ukraine and we'll send so I mean
who knows like what our line was that's
what I'm interested to know did we have
a line was there like a line where like
Russia was asking for a b and c and we
were like nah
we got your Merchant of death
he he's on the table Who you gonna give
us
so
I don't know
you know what I mean and like
I fully understand that there's no way
that they're gonna tell us everything
you know what I mean
they're not going to tell us everything
and then like if you're Paul Whelan's
family and then you hear they go well
they don't want to trade they only
they're only going to do it for her
like I understand Paul Wheeler's family
being like well let's wait then let's
what else do they want we can get him
out with her
and then they're like we have a
Russian's like look this is it
so it's like it's so nuanced and like
imagine being a fly on the wall
hearing
all this stuff like on paper was it a
great trade
maybe not right but like who are we to
decide what the value of
a human being is
uh based off their merits or what they
do or how famous they are or whatever I
mean apparently this happens a lot that
there are a lot of like American people
in Russian prisons for like trumped-up
charges or whatever the thing is and
we're constantly in some negotiation
about like yo can you let our people go
please you know we'll give you this this
and this so you know it's like let's
stop acting like we're not like
we are we are a global economy so you
know we're buying oil from this country
in that country while we're in war with
the same country like I mean it's so
bizarre it's so weird so like I'm saying
it's like we're not you know this is
about what do they say in movies all the
time this is above my pay grade
you know this is above my pay grade I
mean I feel like I would have you know
while the merchant guy if he's so
terrible if he's done such heinous
things you know you know just give him
some slow
acting poison or something we go oh here
he is and then we find out Merchant got
sick he's sick two weeks later he's very
ill you know
I don't know man
it's like it's it's just it's very
bizarre so like I say I don't know
because like because when these kind of
things happen
you know people do a deep dive on a
person
so whatever Brittany greiner's past
public or private
that is being called into question
whether she is worthy of trading such a
valuable
Target of enemy Target that a prisoner
such as this Merchant guy
so
that's really I don't really have too
much more
to say about that because
I'm just I guess I'm really just calling
for people just have a little have a
have some
sympathy have some empathy for her
family and understand where they're
coming from you know it's so it's so
easy for people to be like well I
wouldn't have done that uh you know it's
like Trump put out some nasty stuff
about it you know just being like you
know she don't even love America and all
this kind of stuff but we'll you know
we'll see who knows what who knows it's
done it's happened it's done you know
what I mean it's done we got the guy we
sent him back okay whatever take your
guy who cares
like what's he gonna do now a guy been
in jail 14 years maybe he changed his
ways maybe he's been in prison like you
know what he's told a bunch of Secrets
and who knows man you know what I'm
saying who freaking knows but it is what
it is
all right so my Janine girl wrote
something here working two full-time
jobs and it's killing me my bank account
is thick as [__] but I'm scared that I'm
sacrificing my social life too much I'm
single don't want to end up alone help
well I mean
all right listen
I think that
I think that all of you
all of us
take things one step at a time
all right think of I'll use this analogy
with someone yesterday who was like
going through a health thing and it was
really scared and was was telling me how
overwhelmed they are about everything
and I just want to think of your life
or all the situations you have going on
that you're in a burning building okay
and this is why you should just deal
with the problems that are in front of
you and not look ahead because if you
look ahead at problems
you're not going to deal with your
present situation
so I want you to think of yourself your
life like you're in a burning building a
burning apartment building but you're
butt ass naked and you're sitting in
this Burning apartment building
if you're thinking to yourself
oh my God I don't have any clothes
when I get outside I'm going to be naked
and then you panic
when you really should be thinking about
is how am I gonna get out of this
burning building
take it even step further how am I going
to get out of my apartment
my apartment's on fire my floor is on
fire so I you take one step at a time
let me get out of this room
let me get out of this apartment let me
get off this floor let me get out of
this stairwell let me get outside
then let me find some clothes
you know what I mean
because
if you're always concerned about
what this make-believe future that's
going to be because you you're just
putting that all in your head I don't
know what's going to happen I don't know
so am I going to end up alone am I going
to end up this no
stop worrying about all that and just
deal with the things that are right in
front of you
you always have time to do things that
you love so if you have like some so
you're worried about your social life
well okay then make time for other
things make sure you're taking care of
yourself make sure you eat right make
sure you're trying to get a little
exercise in you know if if your job is
too much make sure you're taking time
for yourself and as you take while
you're taking time for yourself then you
worry about oh okay well now let me see
if I can get on dating apps or go out to
bars or go out to things that uh
interest me and then you know take those
times and you tell yourself well I'm
doing those things well maybe let me see
you let me look around
you know that's what we don't do enough
of put take it put your head up look
around and see who's there
next thing you know you meet someone you
meet another person maybe do you have
interest with this person next thing you
know you guys are going on a date or
maybe it's not romantic now and you say
well now I've made a new friend who
knows but that's what's in front of you
all right
anyways
uh last thing I want to talk about
um today is like I was thinking about
I haven't really I didn't watch a lot of
movies in 2022 this year and I watched a
lot of movies I didn't go to the
theaters a lot I think I went to the
movies this year maybe six times
as opposed to every time I would go on
the road before I would go watch a movie
I just haven't really been interested in
watching movies and I was wondering like
well what's the list of top ghosting
movies this year and uh did I even see
any of these movies so here's the top
roasting list from Box Office Mojo which
is a good source for looking at box
office stuff and of course the top movie
of the year was Top Gun Maverick and I
saw this and it made 1.4 billion dollars
worldwide and that's crazy that this is
Tom Cruise's highest grossing movie of
all time 30 years 30 years in the
business and he's made you I could think
a hit that he's made and I go oh wow
this was the highest grossing one so you
got Top Gun I saw it in the theaters
Jurassic world Dominion 1 billion
worldwide I didn't see that in the
theaters I saw that on like peacock
actually
I think was it peacock it was something
like that
Doctor Strange Multiverse Madness saw it
in the theaters
I'm so so on it
minions the rise of Guru didn't see it
Batman
saw it
I think I saw her a couple times too
long
black panther wakanda saw that in the
theaters
all right so that's three that's on the
sore love and thunder four saw that in
the theaters
uh fantastic okay Watergate Bridge
didn't see that this movie made 600
million dollars worldwide and only a
hundred thousand domestic
but it made 600 million worldwide I
don't know what what freaking movie is
this I got what is this let's let's see
what this is anybody know what movie
This is the Watergate Bridge I don't
even know what the hell this is
wait what's going on with my mouse oh
here we go
um well okay sequel to the battle at
Lake whatever this is looks like a
Chinese oh follows the Chinese people
volunteers soldiers on the new task and
they're now their Battlefield is a
crucial bridge on the retreat of a route
of American troops oh
okay
wow
so we're the enemy in this movie
ain't that something huh y'all so we're
the enemy in this Chinese movie I guess
that's fair because we make movies all
the time where
Arab countries and Asian countries are
the bad guys and then those are big
action box office movies it didn't even
occur to me
that other countries make action movies
where we are the villains and we get
beat up well apparently that's what this
movie is and it's a sequel and it made
600 million worldwide ain't that a [__]
ah all right okay so I didn't see that
one in theaters
Fantastic Beasts and the secrets of
Dumbledore I saw that in the theaters
didn't like it Sonic the Hedgehog didn't
see that Uncharted didn't see that Black
Adam I saw in theaters Elvis I saw in
theaters okay
I saw a bunch of these in theaters I saw
bullet train in theaters
bad guys didn't see that light year
didn't see that in theaters too cool
didn't see that smile nice view didn't
see that DC League of Super Pets didn't
see that in theaters I'm looking down
here what did I see in theaters morbius
I saw in theaters so maybe I saw like 10
or 11 movies that tells me that before I
was watching like a hundred movies Maybe
um yeah where the Crawdad sing you
haven't seen that uh uh let me see some
of these other movies I don't even know
any of these movies Dragon Ball super
superhero didn't see that leaders
jackass forever didn't see that in
theaters
uh Moon fall I didn't see that in
theaters terrible
I'm telling you right now
this movie Moon fault let's see if it's
the right one I'm thinking of
yeah oh my God oh my God that movie was
so bad
um
here's another one that has no domestic
oh these two right here have no domestic
box office huh
all right
uh marry me I didn't see none of these
I'm trying to see if I saw any of these
yeah I see none of these none of these
in the rest of these in the theaters
um wow well they really wow can you
imagine that Harry Potter and the
Chamber of Secrets was re-released in
the the worldwide just to re-release it
and it's still it made 22 million
dollars
I mean God damn that movie just keeps
going I wonder what the highest grossing
movies are of all time let's see all
time all time
um
oh wait wait
okay let's go
worldwide
okay
oh this is year 22. oh we want to go all
time how do you see that oh this okay I
don't know what I'm doing guys
yeah this is okay let's just go to Box
Office Mojo
okay here we go
all right and you go all time
all time chart domestic worldwide
okay here we go
top lifetime grosses
Avatar
wow
Avatar is still the record holder and I
I care nothing about Avatar like the new
ones coming out and I'm hearing it's
supposed to be the most spectacular
thing you've ever seen on screen but
imagine it's been 10 years and you know
this one Avatar we went to go see it and
we were like wow everybody saw it and
then we just completely forgot about it
we don't care about the world the
character is nothing it's the strangest
phenomenon right so all right
top lifetime grosses okay here we go I
finally found it all right so
lifetime grosses of all time is Avatar
in 2009 imagine that there hasn't been a
movie to beat that
oh Avengers end game makes sense we
built up to that imagine you're James
Cameron and you have two of the top
grossing movies of all time Avatar and
Titanic oh this is such an interesting
list man the worldwide lifetime gross as
opposed to the domestic growth it's such
a difference all right so we got Avatar
number one end game number two Titanic
Number Three Star Wars the Force awakens
really
uh
wow at number four Infinity Ward five
Spider-Man no way home at six wow that's
a new one that was 2021. Jurassic world
which was in 2015 at seven The Lion King
good for The Lion King now is this the
wow and the new one too not even the
cartoon in 2019 The Avengers and nine
and Furious 7.
you're telling me
Furious 7 made the top 10 highest
grossing movies worldwide of all time
what is the world coming to top gun
Maverick is already at 11.
Frozen is Frozen two not even Frozen one
Frozen two at number 12.
Avengers Age of Ultron then Black
Panther and then here we go with Harry
Potter
Star Wars episode 3 at
um
oh what is that the Last Jedi
wow none of the none of the good ones
from my era
then Beauty and the Beast from 2017.
isn't that what this is crazy y'all and
then Incredibles 2 at number 20. wow
there's another the fate of the Furious
at number 21. isn't that bananas y'all
so I wonder if we can look up okay
here's worldwide you know what domestic
you know what I like to look at oh you
can't look at it like on this one but I
like to look at International versus
domestic because that's amazing how that
changes
look at this domestic box office just us
here
Avatar goes down to number four and it
goes Force awakens really
that's really amazing to me Avengers end
game spotting no way home and Avatar and
top gun Maverick is a top five
I saw all those in the theaters man
saw all those in the theaters anyway
this is just a chill episode just also
because I like you know I had to do my I
had to do my podcast I have to finish it
you know what I mean
um but I want to thank everybody for
watching the show listening to the show
um you know look out for that content
I've been telling you about that's gonna
It's Gonna Come
I promise you that on on patreon YouTube
members so you could be a YouTube member
patriarch member these are all the ways
you can support me financially okay
super chats right here you got Instagram
uh subscriber uh Twitter super follower
patreon twitch YouTube member on either
Eric Griffin gaming or on here or just
you can go to my bio on this and if you
just want to be like here's a tip Griff
I love you there's another way to do
that too right so many different ways
to modify
and then here's a rude ass comment you
old as hell that's rude like like why
would you why would you say that
I don't know I don't know why what what
has inspired that you know what I mean
what's it I do I'll take food stamps
uh you guys are I hate I hate all y'all
you know that's that's sometimes y'all
just too much
I will not take any bootleg DVDs we're
not gonna do that
I don't know why why am I old as hell
I'm still waiting I'm still waiting for
that dude who just got called out tell
me why I'm old as hell mofo
you know I don't understand that you go
say something like that at least respond
at least like follow up you know what I
mean if you think that's old wait till I
hit you with
until I hit you with this
you know
because you know what time it is y'all
you know what time it is you know what
time it is
every every week we got
to rap recap
[Music]
don't turn your back
thank you
again
somebody tell your friend
[Music]
Box Office Mojo
this is fine dojo
[Music]
teaching that karate
chat getting Bodied
Avatar
High School of all time
look in the mirror
find us one
okay well sometimes when y'all gonna uh
send a beat in you got to make sure the
beat is long
you gotta make sure to be is long enough
that I could do a full-on
[Laughter]
for my dude Chris you Chris you out
there he sent me so many he got like
it's just dope beat after dope beat from
this guy which I probably use like one
or two of these before in the past but
we'll finish it off with this one
okay
two Chris you beats in the show in a row
this is the rap recap Eric Griffin
running the show
once again
I don't pretend
old as [__]
I don't give a [__] 50 years old
[Music]
and stay alive
podcasts will drive
[Music]
[__] he old as [__] but he don't give a
[__]
thanks for watching again hit the likes
and tell your friends
get see you next week don't pretend you
know you like me
[Music]
cause you can't see me
ever Griffin is the G
say can you see
[Music]
all right y'all
I'm all out of raps
I'll see you guys next week
thanks for being here
Eric Griffin Griffin with Griffin
[Music]
thanks for being here
oh you know what
foreign
[Laughter]
we can't even go yet you know I gotta do
this now I might have to like do an edit
and bring it back in later but we got to
do it now because I forgot
better help
when you do it
commercials so we
can do the commercial I'm all about
better help I'm all about online therapy
and this
show referral Griffin is sponsored by
better help all right it's the largest
online therapy Surfers better help has
matched 3 million people with
professional license and license therapy
which is 100 online I've used it I think
it's great sometimes you feel
embarrassed that you don't want to go
into the office or sometimes what's
great about it is you can pick one
therapist and maybe it's not going the
way you want that lets you get a
different one you could choose the right
one and get that match because look
therapy is not going to solve your
problems I'm telling you that right now
it don't solve your problems but what it
does
what therapy does is help you organize
your thoughts with a professional that's
going to help you see the root causes of
your issues and then maybe you can
attack them that way as the largest
therapy service better help us match
three million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
100 online plus it's affordable just
fill out a brief questionnaire to match
with the therapist and if and if things
are clicking you can easily switch to a
new therapist anytime that's like I said
earlier if it's not clicking you could
do it it couldn't be any easier no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Griffin that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash Griffin boom
well I had to get that in
probably on the audio got to move that
to the middle but anyways you guys have
been absolutely fantastic thanks for
being here once again this has been
riffing with Griffin and we are